ah captain you're at my desk just what I
want to see first thing in the morning
you're three minutes late Peralta not my
fault
I had a plumbing problem which reminds
me I'm gonna need a new departmentally
issued phone come on really I'm a few
minutes late so you're gonna call me out
in front of everyone
good idea everyone gather round so I can
call out Peralta in front of you okay
fine I was three minutes late I'm sorry
for doing one thing wrong oh it's more
than one thing let's start with the
Christophe murder there's an amazing
solve I got him to confess in 20 minutes
you also mislabeled the evidence so that
confession is worthless if the sergeant
hadn't caught your mistake here are
three cases with sloppy paperwork here
are two pictures one is your locker the
other is a garbage dump in the
Philippines can you tell which is which
that one's the dump
they're both your locker I should've
guessed that it's good this folder is
labeled undies comma dirty so I won't
confuse it with undies comma clean also
who cares about all these rules I have
more felony arrests than any other
detective here you also have more mice
living in your desk and then any other
detective Algernon
you guys Algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together now
you